il n'y a eu qu'une seule voix cet après
midi devant la presse les membres de
l'association des victimes et familles
de victimes d'anésthésie ont vécu ces 24
dernières heures dans l'angoissé
désormais l'incompréhension nous sommes
profondément choqués de cette décision
contenue des charges qui pèsent
aujourd'hui contre lui il est
inconcevable pour nous qu'il reste libre
1 l'association qui regroupe à ce jour
24 victimes se félicite de la décision
du procureur de faire appel du maintien
en liberté du docteur pesci on considère
pas que que sa liberté laisse entendre
son innocence
on ne considère pas non plus que sa mise
en détention soient le fruit de sa
culpabilité sur est certaine évidemment
on reste prudent à ce sujet mais au vu
des charges des éléments à charge qui
ont été rajoutés hier avec ses 17 cas la
balance pèse très fortement sur le côté
de la culpabilité aujourd'hui on sait
que ce sera long on connaît les délais
de la justice
on s'attend pas à voir un procès dans
quelques semaines ou dans quelques mois
mais on l'attend effectivement avec
impatience un sentiment
d'incompréhension partagée par les
parents du petit et 10 victimes à quatre
ans de deux arrêts cardiaques lors d'une
intervention bénigne ils ont exprimé
leurs sentiments par la voix de leurs
conseils et décidé de diffuser une photo
de l'enfant au moment des fêtes pour
mettre un visage sur le mot victime
cet enfant est opérée à la clinique
saint vincent
nous sommes en 2016 et va subir deux
arrêts cardiaques d'une durée
particulièrement longue et quasiment 20
min
cette photo a été prise alors qu'il est
toujours dans le coma et l'équipe
médicale est dans l'incapacité et c'est
bien naturel et normal de dire si cet
enfant va se réveiller
voilà cette réalité que les parents
veulent faire comprendre
et voilà la raison pour laquelle elle
est aujourd'hui présenté ce n'est pas
dans un contexte de sensationnalisme
loin s'en faut mais ils ont le sentiment
que il y a une certaine désincarnation
qui a été fait de ce dossier les charges
ce matin le procureur de république a
confirmé avoir interjeté appel de cette
décision de maintien en liberté du
docteur peschier pour les victimes et
les familles de victimes le parcours
judiciaire s'annonce interminable